I came to this video playing grim masses
new kid from Turkey and just checked
I've got absolutely no point against the
sky zero out of three this isn't great
Kings Indian think I played epilator
this exchange line before and had a good
position but lost so I'll play this
again and yeah I don't really feel like
playing a super complicated position
today so let's just play though and gave
him usually there go Bishop d7 first not
sure that a 4 is the reason though
okay let's see i have i have some sort
of deja vu feeling like I had to head
this on the board before not sure if it
was against this player or some some
other guy okay so should I play yeah if
i take it feels like i'm i'm developing
him doesn't doesn't seem right maybe Jim
long castles also strange-looking news
okay i don't i don't really see a great
one so let's play that
it takes with the bishop it's not really
threatening to take on me for some
because of the pin so maybe I can
improve the King here and that playbooks
you one let's go back maybe a loud
bishops III yeah this is are still a
very very drawn wish position could be
one and yeah I can you can even play
room v3m
Joe always surprised how quickly people
play play some moves but maybe it's good
hmm well maybe lightly to waste got
bishop age 6 so I can also take my come
on let's take cannot really be bad form
for white with the porn okay I'll be
three heart of course to to do anything
here in terms of winning let's clear me
is very active take here's got rookie
form
night h form this is some the idea
attacking the some slightly weak pawn it
if you defense now I have rocker look on
the sixth-ranked on my derives not a bet
not a bad square
yeah and after all we get a shop
somewhat sharp position this night is
really strong let's see
but those pawns and they're also also
dangerous
hmm interesting i have three
and check yeah I'm not not sure if if
this is good check
we move the king of play 95 number
taking you for this was from bitter ones
bit on the safe side but gras our third
Jim maybe I should should take the draw
with sir it's a draw the time is a
slight issue check but I've got one
minute girl Alfred yeah he's right of
course come on you're authorized this
doesn't make much sense his head of the
pawn and it's just just completely dead
wrong okay but yeah I played it a bit a
bit on the safe side him and then I
think add some chances I was a bit
scared him after this how try to be more
ambitious let's say I give this check
check and now his King looks to be in a
bit of a precarious situation a look
brooke d 1 rock t6 you know but he's got
to f3 yeah let's for example say i play
this one he takes and lucas e6 and I was
afraid that he's got a big counterattack
coming with this muth that's a here for
example just check for God's sake now
even that one is completely crazy but my
king is a present role until mean losing
Jim very tricky
you know this is why I went droopy a 97
to play it safe with with about a minute
down on time the come / once to wants to
play for win here with my checks check
then look a six-hour this is this is
very difficult to find for a human
player almost a zoosk one type of
position yeah it weighed won't check you
that wants to play that now I would hear
but here widest sir what is probably
really better I mean it's a pawn and I
can I don't really see at the moment how
it's going to break through with those
it's of course not a simple technical
position but then this is something
white can try would have ok six is very
computer stuff complicated yeah quite
often it it gets it gets tricky and even
those kind of quite delish positions he
was very very quickly going doing for
that yeah here of course i also had 92
but i like i like this idea ready to go
for a five now very complicated I guess
the draw a son is not a particularly
unjust result thanks for watching